oui surtout qu'on a on a vraiment
découvert des choses ce matin on a
découvert ce matin ils étaient
pratiquement les seuls à ignorer
l'existence de ces étranges personnages
imaginaires qui sont venues du japon qui
fascinent les enfants qui on l'a dit et
qui parfois inquiète les parents oui et
nous avons découvert que les cartes
représentant ces drôles de bestioles
comme pikachu et rondoudou ont
littéralement envahi les cours de
récréation c'est un véritable troc qui
s'est organisée alors pour bien
comprendre ce phénomène pierre emmanuel
luneau et sophie n'est ni honte
enquêtaient dans une école de rouen
voilà en quelques mois les cours de
récréation été littéralement envahis par
ce nouveau phénomène venu du japon
les enfants en oublierait presque le
traditionnel ballon de foot charge les
deux frères et des petits personnages
comme cela il en existe plus de 150 les
pokémon abréviation de monstres de poche
c'est décline sur plusieurs supports
carte à jouer jeux vidéo ou même peluche
en fait quand on en a attrapé un
difficile de s'en séparer
r oh ça je les connais tous les 150 juge
oui
sans un phénomène de mémoire pour
retenir tous les noms des personnages
des reconnaître on va on aimerait bien
voir ça en conjugaison en mathématiques
du côté des fournisseurs on se frotte
les mains
le phénomène n'a vraiment débuté en
france qu'à l'automne dernier mais déjà
près d'un million de jeux vidéo ont été
écoulés en six mois les cartes si nous
les recevons par camions circulent
toutes les nuits mettons en place le
matin avant l'ouverture et ensuite
toutes les demi-heures un travail de
remplissage permanent de façon à garder
une disponibilité maximale du produit
n'ont plus du tout on n'a plus du tout
cartes pokémon sa porte comme des petits
pains d'autres dans dix minutes on les
reçoit pendant la plus chère du tout
au japon où le jeu est né il ya quatre
ans le phénomène prend aujourd'hui une
ampleur considérable
les pokémon sont partis et lors du
lancement du 151e personnages de la
série
les forces de l'ordre ont dû intervenir
pour maîtriser la foule
aujourd'hui pokémon au niveau mondial
représente un chiffre d'affaires global
de 7 milliards de dollars
ce chiffre d'affaires est en progression
constante puisque il y à un lancement en
europe qui n'a que six mois alors qu'aux
états unis ça fait déjà deux ans une
invasion planifié donc mais est elle
vraiment du goût de tous les parents je
connais j'en ai entendu parler mais on a
lutté contre dorothée à l'époque de
dorothée aujourd'hui on essaie de lutter
contre les pokémon de cette lutte je ne
sais pas encore qui va l'emporter en
attendant aux dernières nouvelles le
cours du pokémon est à la hausse pour
vous de parler du cours de l'avant je
vais me permets de vous offrir h et d'un
pic à chaud donc c'est le héros préférés
bien les enfants et je remercie le
risque qui nous a cédé pendant quelques
instants c'est maurice et objets voilà
ces objets si précieux ça va mal à
matches suivants du coup et cours de la
bourse
alors
c'est la folie des pokémon nous y avons
consacré une émission il ya quelques
semaines sur région pointent comme et
cette mode n'est pas encore retombée ces
images à collectionner font un tabac
dans les cours de récréation mais aussi
dans les salles de classe et c'est bien
le problème
les élèves sont moins attentifs du coup
dans certaines écoles ont confisqué ses
pokémon et on envisage même de les
interdire
reportage de france 3 à amiens voici des
pokémon mais s'écarte là sont déjà
réservées dans les bureaux de tabac sont
en rupture de stock depuis plusieurs
mois pourtant la demande est toujours
très forte
les mamans surtout viennent pour les
enfants parce qu'ils ont faim réclament
à cor et à cri mais dans la possible on
peut quand même pas facile a enfin on
essaie de les faire patienter un petit
peu pour mieux comprendre il faut aller
dans les cours d'école l'ambiance est
frénétique on y rencontre des gentils
pokémon des méchants pokémon explication
est à peu près comme une bête
et puis ça soit de sa pokémon sol air ou
pourquoi s'intéresse à sa façon à la
télé et oui les pokémon c'est surtout un
grand phénomène médiatique et commercial
qui peut perturber la quiétude des
salles de classe via les échanges entre
l image presque l armement de
collectionneurs de ces images-là et
donc c'est vrai que c'est le plus beau
coup leurs esprits sains comme ces
petits c'est très facile de mettre dans
la poche en pièces les chouchous sont
vendus avec qu'on retrouva partout dans
la cour et même dans les salles ce qui
est quand même pas évident encore pour
l'instant ici les pokémon ne sont pas
interdits d'école même si des
collections ont déjà été confisqués mais
il ne faut pas oublier que c'est avant
tout une mode qui passera sans doute
même si pour l'instant elle reste bien
ancré sur les têtes
et alors c'est pas
mais pokemon en fait c'est un mot
anglais qui est un peu contracté ça veut
dire pocket monsters en anglais c'est
toi qu'est la reine de l'anglais oui ça
veut dire monstres de poche petit
monstre quoi alors comme d'hab certes un
petit veinard ont eu la chance de voir
pokémon de en avant première et voici
donc les tout premiers avis sur ce film
en deux alors qu'il était bien ce que y
avait des nouveaux keohane
la dation
j'aime bien pikachu et je trouve union 6
passes cuisine vedette c'est le premier
pokémon qui a été connu alors qu'il
manquait ce que j'adore le puits soro
bon bah soyons concret vous avez
beaucoup beaucoup aimé